♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
How you doing tonight?
Yeah, me too.
This sucks.
What are you gonna do about it?
Hey, I know.
Let's do a monologue
without an audience.
Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
and Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer
announced today
they had reached a deal
on a coronavirus
economic stimulus package.
Unfortunately, they shook on it
and are now in quarantine.
The White House
and Senate leaders
struck a deal this morning
over a $2 trillion
coronavirus stimulus package,
$1.9 trillion
to bail out cruise lines
plus a dozen surgical masks
for New York City.
President Trump's White House
doctor announced last week
that Trump had tested negative
for the coronavirus,
which means Trump has still
never passed a single test
in his life.
[ As Donald Trump ]
Maybe cholesterol?
Can we line me up
for one of those?
[ Normal voice ] That's right --
The White House doctor announced
that President Trump had tested
negative for coronavirus,
though he did have something
called McRib lung.
Democratic Party officials
are reportedly considering
a range of contingency plans
for their upcoming
national convention in July,
including hosting
a "virtual convention."
Oh, God.
Please don't make Joe Biden
learn Skype.
[ As Joe Biden ] "Www"?
That's not even a word.
Back in my day, we had a little
something called vowels, buster.
[ Normal voice ]
Not a good Biden.
Despite administration officials
cautioning
that it's too early to tell
if an anti-malarial drug
will cure the coronavirus,
President Trump told reporters,
"I feel good about it.
Just a feeling.
I am a smart guy."
So we don't know if
the malaria drug will work,
but whatever drug Trump is on
works great.
A New York strip club
has launched
virtual-reality lap dances
for patrons to stream at home.
Or if you don't have VR goggles,
you can just burn a $100 bill
while you listen to Whitesnake.
Yesterday was
National Cocktail Day,
said Americans at 9:00 a.m.
According to reports, disgraced
movie mogul Harvey Weinstein
has tested positive
for the coronavirus in prison.
So for once, he's the one
who can say, "Me too."
That's right -- Harvey Weinstein
has tested positive
for the coronavirus in prison,
so if you've been in close
contact with Harvey Weinstein,
I have even more bad news.
A woman in New Mexico
was arrested over the weekend
for stealing a car and telling
officers she was Beyoncé.
But in her defense,
she only said she was Beyoncé
so she could get
a coronavirus test.
According to reports,
divorce lawyers in Manhattan
have experienced
an increase in calls
due to the coronavirus
quarantine.
And if you're wondering why
they're open during a pandemic,
in New York, divorce
is an essential business.
A man in New Hampshire
was arrested on Monday
after he allegedly chased a
neighbor with a 2 1/2-foot sword
because he asked him
to turn down his music.
Dude, are you crazy?
That sword has to be
at least six feet.
You're vector, buddy.
Organizers of the National High
School Musical Theatre Awards
have announced that due to
the coronavirus pandemic,
this year's competition
has been canceled
because it's too depressing
to hear the kids
from "A Chorus Line"
sing, "God, I hope I get it."
Matt Goldich wrote that joke.
You can follow him on Twitter
and complain.
That's right --
the National High School
Musical Theatre Awards
have been canceled,
and they want to remind everyone
to wash your...hands!
And finally, a woman in Missouri
recently gave birth last week
in the toilet paper aisle
of a Walmart.
Said the woman, "That means
I can get two rolls, right?"
Hey, everybody,
that was a monologue.
And we're just
trying it out here.
We got a new microphone.
So maybe this sounds
a little bit better.
I think our lighting's
I can hear a lawn mower,
so maybe you've been able to
this whole time, as well.
Wash your hands.
Stay safe.
We love you.
Thanks for watching.